[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je reçois
aujourd'hui Sania de fête Kova
secrétaire général de l'onde à Vélizy
bonjour bonjour alors la saison
2022 2023 s'achève bientôt il reste
cependant quelques spectacles à venir
découvrir à Londres quels sont les
ambitions de la salle de spectacle sur
le territoire
déjà s'adresser au plus grand nombre et
puis être un lieu de rencontre de
rencontre artistique humaine on a vécu
une année un peu compliqué beaucoup de
salles de spectacles l'année dernière
avec la reprise après covid et là on est
très heureux de voir que les gens
reviennent et que les lieux de culture
redeviennent des lieux de rencontre
justement donc voilà c'est s'adresser au
plus grand nombre c'est une mauvaise
période finalement un peu un peu oubliée
grâce à la venue alors revenus on va
dire de des visiteurs des spectateurs et
vous vous proposez des spectacles des
expositions des rencontres et des temps
forts pourquoi ne pas avoir voulu vous
concentrer seulement sur une
programmation de spectacle et de concert
pour avoir une diversité dans les
disciplines on reste à un théâtre de
ville c'est important que chacun puisse
trouver des spectacles à son goût et à
la fois on est aussi conventionnés par
le ministère de la Culture pour
développer un programme autour de la
danse on est cinq conventionnelle danse
donc voilà on a autant de la danse que
des arts plastiques puisqu'il y a un
centre d'art que des spectacles de
théâtre du jeune public aussi des trois
ans donc voilà la diversité est très
très importante mais du 30 mai au 8 juin
vous organisez le festival Lumière
qu'est-ce que ce festival alors c'est un
temps fort de de restitution on met la
lumière sur tous les projets d'action
culturels qui ont lieu pendant la saison
donc c'est une partie moins visible de
notre travail mais qui est essentiel
donc sur l'année on compte à peu près
une vingtaine de projets par an qui qui
sont menées avec des artistes
professionnels le plus souvent des
artistes qu'on accueille dans le cadre
de la saison et ça va des maternelles il
y a des projets cette année par exemple
il y avait un projet autour du théâtre
d'ombre avec des élèves de maternelle
donc ça ça brasse toutes les tous les
deux ré tous les niveaux et aussi des
projets avec des groupes d'amateurs de
danse de théâtre donc c'est l'occasion
pour de montrer leur travail et de le
faire dans des conditions
professionnelles voilà on les accueille
comme des pros et pendant 10 jours il
montre le fruit de leur travail avant de
parler de la programmation j'aimerais
que vous me présentiez de l'exposition
les vagues qui est à découvrir jusqu'au
1er juillet quel est l'intérêt de cette
de cette exposition c'est notre dernière
exposition de la saison le Centre d'Art
de Londres est un lieu de production on
invite des artistes qui créent pour le
lieu pour l'occasion on peut avoir des
preuves mais là en l'occurrence il
s'agit d'une exposition de cet artiste
tout jeune qui qui sont tout fraîchement
diplômés de l'École Nationale Supérieure
des Arts Décoratifs donc pour la plupart
d'entre eux c'est la première fois
qu'ils exposent dans dans un centre
d'art et c'est cette version de enfin de
comment ils approchent la notion de
l'espace comment créer un espace dans
l'espace pour certains c'est l'espace de
refuge pour d'autres c'est l'espace de
d'expérimentation
l'espace du rêve dont chacun
l'interprète à sa manière ce qui donne
une vraie diversité au niveau des œuvres
exposées et pour nous c'est voilà ça
fait partie aussi de nos missions
d'accompagner ces jeunes artistes là et
de leur donner une visibilité sur une
période assez conséquente d'avril à
juillet c'est votre rôle finalement
c'est aussi donc d'accompagner mais de
valoriser aussi les jeunes artistes les
artistes émergents et pour pour cette
pardon niveau spectacle parce qu'on a
déjà parlé de l'exposition donc jusqu'au
1er juillet c'est bien ça jusqu'au 1er
juillet niveau spectacle une bonne
surprise attendez Yvelines moi le 10
juin prochain vous proposez un spectacle
en déambulation dans l'espace public
avec Willy Dorner qu'est-ce que ça
signifie une déambulance une
déambulation dans l'espace public ça
veut dire que le public va se balader et
suivre à un groupe de performeurs
vêtu de survêtement très très colorés
qu'on va retrouver un briquet dans
l'architecture ur dans des positions un
peu improbables oui leader il crée ses
figures humaines qui qui il est un
brique vraiment dans l'architecture et
c'est des spectacles vraiment créés sur
mesure à chaque fois il y a un casting
après il y a une petite semaine de
création et ça donne vraiment des
ambulations vraiment uniques et pour
nous c'est l'occasion de fêter
l'anniversaire une troisième fois cette
année avec tous les vélisiens avec tous
les Yvelines noirs avec toute personne
qui qui aimeraient faire partie de cet
anniversaire il faut bien entendu
réserver pourquoi ce spectacle peut être
considéré comme une idée prodigieuse
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne voit
finalement pas souvent non non il passe
nulle part en France cette année c'est
notre directeurs la vue il y a quelques
années à Montréal je crois et ça fait un
moment qu'on qui veut l'inviter et on
s'est dit pour les 20 ans de Londres on
cherche des rendez-vous à l'extérieur
pour fêter ça avec tout le monde gratuit
et ça m'est vraiment en valeur
l'architecture de la ville donc voilà
pour les 20 ans de Londres on s'est dit
c'est le spectacle il faut et c'est donc
le 10 juin à 11h et à 18h il y aura deux
voilà deux représentations elle sera
également suivie d'un ciné concert en
partenariat avec le ciné-club de Vélizy
qu'est-ce qui attend les spectateurs
pour ce ciné concert et bien à l'issue
de la deuxième déambulation ils pourront
rester avec nous sur le parvis de
Londres on fera un grand pique-nique et
puis on va profiter des beaux jours pour
pour redécouvrir Frankenstein dans sa
version de 1931 et c'est un signe et
concert on a passé commande à Joachim
Latarget pour la musique donc même ceux
qui connaissent le film ça sera une
découverte une redécouverte assez
spéciale parce que la musique est
vraiment composée pour l'occasion
urban space et le ciné concert donc ça
se passe le 10 juin on poursuit avec
l'origine du monde les 15 et 16 juin que
va raconter la pièce
alors là on est sur une proposition qui
situe entre le spectacle de théâtre une
vraie fausse conférence une vente aux
enchères en fait Nicolas et il y a un
jour sur une brocante trouve une copie
du tableau L'Origine du monde de Gustave
Gustave Courbet et bon c'est une copie
qui est pas très réussie mais les
dimensions sont exactement les mêmes que
l'original
il questionne enfin les questions sur le
prix ça coûte 200 euros et là d'un coup
il part dans une réflexion sur la valeur
de l'art la valeur des de l'argent la
valeur des choses en général et du coup
il raconte un peu
l'histoire de comment il a trouvé ce
tableau là quelles sont les différences
entre une reproduction et une copie et
je dis vente aux enchères parce que
c'est une vraie vente aux enchères enfin
on pourrait acheter le tableau pendant
le spectacle mais tout en sachant que si
quelqu'un l'achète le spectacle s'arrête
de tourner donc ça sera un spectacle qui
sera donné dans la galerie du centre
d'art pas en salle c'est on sait jamais
trop ce qui est vrai ce qui est faux
enfin ça c'est une forme assez très
particul Ière très ludique c'est aussi
ça le théâtre c'est faire voyager se
faire questionner ne plus savoir où on
est finalement
et du 21 au 24 juin classique revisité
Don Juan tout le monde connaît
l'histoire de ce séducteur compulsif en
tout cas comment moi je le vois est-ce
que la pièce collera parfaitement à
l'oeuvre originale
parfaitement je ne sais pas
ce que ça reste quand même une version
moderne mais c'est proposée par la
troupe de la Comédie Française qui mieux
qui de mieux pour présenter Molière que
la Comédie Française
nous sommes dans une version très très
épurée c'est un plateau casino un espèce
de ring en bois avec des miroirs tout
tout et à l'intérieur les cinq
personnages qui qui mènent la pièce
c'est des voilà c'est des comédiens
excellents c'est ça sera très très
fidèle au texte et après dans la mise en
mise en scène ça ça décale un petit peu
et le 24 juin les Yvelinois pourront
sont invités pardon à venir découvrir la
saison 2023 2024 de Londres quelles sont
vos ambitions justement pour cette
prochaine saison
les ambitions terme artistiques ont
contenu le développement de la danse ça
sera notre deuxième année de
d'accompagnement de notre artiste en
résidence on dit au camouilleux donc
elle fera sa création sa nouvelle
création dans le cadre d'immersion dans
son novembre et après on continue avec
des propositions aussi encore une fois
très variés
on a voilà un très beau programme en
danse aussi avec des têtes d'affiches
comme Israël Galvan qui qui est une star
du flamenco
Jeanne Gallois pour le hip-hop Medicare
couche qui vient d'être nommé qui prend
la succession de Mourad merzuki au
centre chorégraphique de Créteil et
après on a aussi du jazz avec un passé
haut on a également un grand spectacle
de vertus avec du cirque avec le groupe
acrobatique de Tanger le 29 et 30
septembre en théâtre des pièces assez
variées de d'Alexis Michalik avec le
cerf des États-Unis jusqu'à Iphigénie
proposée par dans une mise en scène
d'interromps et c'est le texte de Thiago
Rodriguez qui est le nouveau directeur
du festival d'Avignon
une grande exposition en partenaire avec
Pompidou et et toute une série de
propositions familiales des trois ans
toujours aussi des expositions des
rencontres et des temps forts tout au
long de tout au long de l'année vous
mettez en place également des
partenariats avec différentes salles de
spectacles pourquoi c'est partenariats
sont nécessaires selon vous on travaille
beaucoup avec la scène nationale des
Yvelines oui
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec l'azimut
également avec d'autres salles ça permet
d'une part une circulation des publics
parfois il y a des spectateurs qui
découvrent une salle parce qu'une autre
salle partenaire les y emmène mais
surtout ça me permet de rester dans une
économie du spectacle qui est plus plus
raisonnable plus responsable puisqu'on
mutualise les moyens donc surtout dans
le cadre des tournées internationaux ça
me permet de d'accueillir des formes que
tout seul on pourrait pas proposer pour
découvrir la prochaine saison ça se
passe le 24 juin donc à Londres à Vélizy
vos portes réouvriront le 15 septembre
prochain merci beaucoup Sania tu fais ce
qu'on va d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation et pour revoir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]